natasha is with us in Louisville hi
Natasha how are you hey how are you
better than I deserve what's up well I'm
very excited to talk to you I just worry
about you about two weeks ago and from
all my bosses have been calling me up he
said cool how can I help today so I'm
about eighty thousand dollars a day will
come
well 32,000 its 481 I have another
twenty thousand and that is a car that
they got repossessed which is about ten
thousand and the left is I have alone as
long so I was trying to help you know
get myself out of debt which is
backwards and credit card Jojo emotional
personal wage um hey Barry I've got
money
that was for five thousand and then I've
got two that were for fifteen hundred
and the rest of credit card for joy
McMillan credit card a total and
probably about nine thousand dollars
okay and you were getting ready tell me
about another car no there's been one
more big thing I have a pain a
restitution payment for an overpayment
that I received and while I was seeing
benefits for my children because they
told me I didn't have to tell about my
VA wages which I had and it was all
wrong so I'm paying it back that's one
hundred and fifty seven dollars a month
picture probably about ten more years
what is the balance the balance is like
twenty thousand bucks on that that's
correct okay
and your question and you're in
household income is what um I get about
42,000 ality it and you're single
yes I am imagine children what are you
driving oh well um I write and all that
involve a $900 cards and oh five so toys
good okay and then your questions what
I'm trying to figure out whether or not
it's a good idea to
Chapter seven bankruptcy no okay here's
why it's not going to do much good the
VA and the student loans are not
bankrupt able that's sixty-two thousand
of your eighty thousand yes and the rest
of its just personal loans credit cards
and an old car repo and the old car repo
can be settled for pennies on the dollar
and for that matter if you're behind on
the student loans and the personal loans
you can probably settle those for
pennies on the dollar you could probably
be debt-free not counting the VA in the
student loan for as little as ten
thousand bucks
just working your way through those
debts you see what I'm saying but the
student loans are not bankrupt able and
neither is the VA they're going to stick
with you through this because it's
government debt in both cases and so if
it moved your needle for you how we talk
about it you know but it's almost all
your debts still going to be there after
bankruptcy and that doesn't that doesn't
do any good now you got a lot of these
little mosquitoes flying around your
head here driving you crazy the all
these little nickel and dime debts I
mean the car repo is probably not
bothering you today right correct and
the have you got student loans on
hardship deferral today um they're
actually on an income based repayment
that just went over so um so how much
are you paying them and $25 than that
okay so we got twenty-five dollars on
the forty two thousand student loans on
the VA you got one hundred and fifty
seven so really neither one of those two
things are killing you today the cars
the old car repos ero today and then the
rest of its just mosquitoes flying
around your head so more than anything
what we've got to do is we gotta get you
organized to get you on a plan to start
paying these things off and get them out
of your life so you can have hope that
it will all go away someday which is
what you were losing if you lose hope
you go I need to go BK right I need to
go bankrupt and but you got to have a
plan where we can walk you out of this
and the way to do that is we're going to
get you on a tight budget go to every
dollar calm download or use the the app
for your iPhone or Android or for your
desktop it's free at every dollar
dot-com start doing your monthly
you're telling every dollar what to do
each and every month every dollar has an
assignment then as you can squeeze money
out of your budget and you can sell
stuff and you can work extra and
anything you can do to create money
we're going to list your debts smallest
to largest and pay minimum payments on
everything but the little ones and we're
going to tack the little one with a
vengeance what's your smallest credit
card debt it's a $300 one see we can
knock that one out fast one down and cut
him up he's gone chopping plastic
surgery okay
then then what's your next smallest one
$100 oh there we go see we got traction
already 700 bucks gets rid of two of
these problems just like that and see
how we can begin to get some traction
then emotionally as well as
mathematically now it's going to slow
down when you get down to those last
three the VA the car repo and the
student loan but the when you get to the
car repo what we're going to just save
up a pile of money and call them how
much are they saying you owe them on
this deficit on this repo it was close
to $2,000 like 9,000 yeah they're
probably they'll probably take up
they'll probably take about 2,000 to
settle that Oh about 20 cents on the
dollar will probably settle it but we
got to have the two thousand and we're
not there yet right so we get all these
little ones out of the way then we save
up two thousand and call those people
negotiate with them I'm going to walk
with you through this and show you how
to do it okay all right I'm going to do
it on the radio you're gonna I'm going
to be here everyday for you and I'm
gonna put you on hold and Laura's going
to pick up we're going to give you a
Financial Peace University our nine week
class to go through to learn how to
handle money and you get on that every
dollar tonight and start your budget and
the first year you get the Financial
Peace University class and get yourself
turned around kiddo we're here to help
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]